shifting gears now ukrainians have been
paying a heavy price since Russia
invaded their country last year
thousands and I mean thousands have lost
arms and legs and that has created an
urgent need for artificial limbs Holly
Williams visited a clinic in Ukraine
providing Prosthetics and Rehabilitation
and met two young Wounded Warriors who
are learning to walk again
signed up for the military two months
after Russia invaded her country a radio
operator she celebrated her 19th
birthday on the front line
but then in February her unit came under
mortar fire
tore off ruslana's left leg
did you realize immediately that you had
lost your leg no
and what did you feel at that point
I grabbed my leg and realized that I was
holding it in my hand just a bone she
told us
I needed to give myself first aid it was
scary it was painful
we met was Lana just four days after she
was fitted with a new prosthetic no
longer on the battlefield
but still a fighter she was already
pushing herself to the limits
told us she planned one day to dance
again Ukraine says more than ten
thousand of its people have lost a limb
during Russia's bloody Invasion a
generation scarred for life
the super
man Center set up far from the front
line is Ukraine's first state-of-the-art
clinic for Prosthetics and
Rehabilitation they started treating
Wounded Warriors here even while
construction workers finished the
building if you look at what Russia has
done uh in Ukraine it's barbaric the
Superhuman Center is funded by the
Howard Buffett Foundation he's the son
of the billionaire Warren Buffett
and says his Charities given Ukraine
nearly 300 million dollars since the
invasion began and buffets visited the
country seven times during the war what
are your impressions of Ukraine and
ukrainians
well I think Ukraine is actually
teaching the world a lesson I think
they're teaching us the kind of
commitment and resiliency uh and fight
that can be
um mustered up against somebody like
Russia
Denise Kevin Co will need every ounce of
resilience he can muster
a triple
triple who told us he lost both legs and
his left arm to an anti-tank rocket but
this former infantry Soldier is so
driven his doctors believe he'll one day
be able to run again
we can't give up he told us we have a
long life ahead of us and we should take
Fate by its horns
we're very good friends just like
Ukraine roslana and Denise never wanted
this war and it's left them shattered
yet like their country their unbroken
and undefeated
for CBS mornings Holly Williams the Viv
Ukraine
I I I'm so sorry we're even still
telling the story about this war that it
still continues over a year later
there's still so many layers to this and
you hear about the statistics of the
wounded and the dead and there are real
people behind that once again we see
that yeah live and up close and
impersonal it's very difficult they're
fighting for their country they're
giving up a lot for it not giving up
Holly ends on the note that I think is
resonant in that country they're
undefeated yeah they continue on and so
very confident well sir despite all the
pain